so uh let's go over
the outward back knuckle
hey you know your jab okay boom this
one's coming
is going to give you a kind of jab like
architecture but it's going to be able
to hit from the side where the chap has
to hit from the face of the target okay
um
again a Bay Point of origin but your
fist might be somewhere somewhere else
okay so if we're from our 5D stance
imagine there's a rope and it's going to
pull my fist boom
and you're gonna hit with these two
knuckles the top portion of them okay
they're not the front side like on a
punch or the top portion of those two
knuckles
uh some
it's a good one all that floating ribs
is a good one okay but we'll just work
it at the at the temple range okay it's
almost like the item so you don't want
to turn your hips into it no hips boom
will kind of go the other way to shove
that shoulder forward okay minimally
uh so to practice it you'll hold
the bag put that side back
okay and there's your target
and it's not a shot where you you're
going to try to send him flying it's
really a lot is how fast this strike
comes back boom bring the strike back
don't plant the back foot you can only
ground off the ball of the foot because
you're rotating that heel to rotate the
claw and to extend the shoulder forward
okay let's try
okay so he's gonna be in his stance all
right uh so just some applications he's
doing his jab right you have your Pawn
techniques okay we're gonna pod into a
into that back knuckle underneath
and then the leg
[Applause]
okay try it
another great application for it is uh
whatever sense you want okay another
good application is all about on you're
going to trap and pass okay so I'm clear
and
and the stripe will hit okay and that's
stuff like you've got your job's got to
find this hole in there okay uh and so a
lot of times if you're if you're gonna
uh attack High you should attack low or
fake low okay so uh we'll do we'll do
this kick and then eventually you could
you could fake it boom
I just here boom boom
clear boom
okay like you can take it
okay try it
all right uh so knife fences grip Hammer
grip okay
your back knuckle
boom if you turn it at the end
you have and you're carrying Hammer grip
boom you'd have your stripe okay so
let's not damage our back here because
they're not made for that so you're kind
of just working the mechanics boom
boom
you say I'm not trying to puncture the
back okay but I'm working the mechanics
comes out exactly the same and at the
end it turns
boom
because we're not going for power this
is a good opportunity to take that
tension off your body and working on
your ground Vector your claw turning
tension out of the shoulder
okay let's try it all right uh
something on carrying it okay
you can disguise things by making them
look natural and what can't look natural
make the rest of what's around it look
unnatural and then it looks naturally
okay so if I'm holding this like that
it's I'm armed okay so uh but if I hold
it like this and the other hand is like
this do you see it still looks unnatural
but if I mimic it
Shield my body and mimic on the other
hand it's a little harder to tell what's
going on okay do you get that you still
see that I'll change it again
now it doesn't like do you see it change
it again okay so we're going to start
the technique from this from this
position okay when it comes to shielding
you have to understand where the 90 is
on your body okay and so you can't
Shield anything in front of that you
have to Shield behind that but you go
too far back now it looks unnatural you
see that so you're you're you've got to
play around at that uh 91 kind of degree
okay tension on your body so he has his
knife
and we'll just work uh mosquito stomach
okay so okay
and we're just working
from that we'll go really slow I just
want you to work on the on the shielding
part okay
near that's what he's doing and then
we'll add our angle deflection so my
hand that's on the outside moves that to
the inside and I step to the outside
okay so here boom
move
poop and then the other knife is coming
up at the bicep okay
so very relaxed
and then from here up you have your
outward background okay don't get too
particular on where you hit like in the
movies
just stand normal anything in the face
is gonna work for what we want okay you
got it so just like the back knuckle
you're it's hard to fight
when a piece of Steel pushed your
eyeball out or there's you get it or
your nose is feel something or you get
teeth knocked out you're already
increasing your odds do you see that so
just like if I if I was empty-handed oh
I just thrown it in his face you get
that tilt right and then you can attack
things okay
so don't
be stay loose okay we're here he goes
and just throw that back knuckle in the
face okay let's just get there try just
a couple things on this sand on point of
origin so when he's coming in I don't
want to turn my hand over and do the
pattern
my hand is here my this hand does the
pair
so on the Prairie I don't want to knock
his hand down either which is another
reason to go here because I'm trying to
go on the bicep I want his bicep to come
into me so
you see that then the knife will bite
deep okay
I'm not necessarily gonna Flip It Up
but I'm definitely not gonna knock it
down okay a couple of things happen
generally when you hit someone in the
bicep they tend to go ah
or another thing that tends to happen
when you hit someone in the face their
shoulders go back you see I'll just show
you if you don't believe me Sean you see
okay do you get it okay and then if you
watch his let's put his arm there or
maybe the camera come over here
put his hand in space
hangers up
10 goes up from bicep cut and goes up
from Face Down okay got it so I go I won
boom pop so the hands going up that's
where I'm gonna come down
okay and I'm gonna buy into that thumb
right on that thumb joint
you feel that right okay so again the
same concept
make the target go the opposite
direction of the knife so I made the
target go the opposite direction of the
knife okay
and instead of filleting the thumb here
I'm actually gonna hook it and drop
him down got it
since we have plastic eyes you won't
have the effect but you can still get it
hook right here and just drop down
check his height as you cut his thumb up
so it just worked uh boom down drop your
weight
don't work any faster because we don't
have the eye Pro on okay got it right
remember okay okay so whoa pop down
there he'll feel that hook just hold but
I'm not grabbing it's really this hand
right Sean okay
okay
foam and just drop your weight
okay let's try it
all right come on the other side so you
all can see come on the other side of
the shot
it's the same thing like uh
the more you have to go into fixated
movement
which was a a an a constant muscle
flexion the slower you're going to be
okay versus ballistically
ballistic move is going to be faster so
can you control somebody with Ballistic
movement or with minimal amount of
fixated movement that's going to be
better
than
grabbing things you're holding things do
you understand okay so
um
for example
this is why one of the latest videos we
did was I told you not to grab
and you see it just it you use your
adhesion in there instead on GG Noggin
got it so you we did our new strikes
boom
[Music]
and you're gonna be much faster you
don't have to take forever so you don't
that's a luxury time's a luxury do you
understand
so the same thing if we're we're here
and we we all know
this takedown right
you get it so this is fixated motion
though you
understand uh you kind of duplicate the
same thing by boom pop you see this is
ballistic
and you did the same
that is much faster you get it but
sometimes you need fixated motion okay
so if you have
a guy's he's going move you can do these
these kind of dislods do you understand
do you see it or not okay I see it can
you see it I missed the end
so boom I'm in here right oh and I'm
going this way I can do that it's doable
but it's gonna be much faster
if I just cut off his thumb
do you see that it's going to be much
faster and this is hard to stab me
without his thumb there okay got it okay
so
you have your knife
and that's what you're doing
following not just boom just shaving
that thing off but you can't shave it
off in training because your knife slips
off you see that you can't shave it off
the train what I tend to do in training
is I end for that butt end like that and
maybe anchor my my body like that okay
um but
so went on this train with Mr Pig we did
things on pieces
butcher meat okay you learn that way I
don't have butcher meat
so this is makeshift so you guys would
understand okay there's some flesh and a
bone do you see that and then you have a
beautiful Randall 15.
so pop you coming out you're gonna come
here and you're gonna purposefully dig
into that bone
all this way and you're just gonna shave
it down and you can see that it's biting
do you see that and that is what you wow
he's cut down and off comes the thumb
okay do you got that we can't duplicate
that with our wood knives and our but
that's what's happening
boom you're gonna get a solid hook in
that thing and if you can drop your
salad oh his face is gonna hit the hit
the ground you got that okay
and so what's your normal reaction when
your face is going to the ground
you're gonna put your hands down you see
that so I'm gonna throw you down and
when I feel you reach for the ground
that's when I cut it off because now I
make the target opposing to my cut okay
so it doesn't just go down I'm dropped
and that's when I feel that knife bite
into it that's when I pull it out you
gotta see you can't just go here
is throat and then once you feel it bite
and you're pulling it up which means the
thumb's coming off Okay so
as you're going into the the training
boom I come back very sharp to the angle
can you see that to bite into it and
that thing
is why I pull his center with so you
don't pull the arm you don't pull the
arm you're going to move his Center
once he starts to fall that's when I cut
up on the knife and
the knife's disarms you now you can
dance around
and you can wait
for your face stabs and maybe deter and
the thumb in front of his face Maybe to
deter you don't have to keep going in
there okay but this is this is well it's
that
it's that quick okay so without the nine
oh that's the action there
okay that's how quick you want that to
be okay all right but we don't have ipro
on
so you're gonna go smooth
nice and slow
again
nonsense
okay excited